[Music]
I want to be around for a long time but
how I use and spend that time is going
to be important from here on out
it's precious and I've never ever
thought that I was at the end of
anything that I was always just
beginning I shall always remember this
rule with a career spanning almost eight
decades british-born Angela Lansbury
started out acting alongside Ingrid
Bergman when she was just a teenager
what do you do I'm all right man my
first time in front of a camera was
Nancy the maid in Gaslight so that was a
wonderful introduction to Motion
Pictures she earned an Oscar nomination
for her very first role then came more
critical Acclaim for various films
throughout her career including 1962's
The Manchurian Candidate in 1971's bed
knobs and Broomsticks but Angela's
biggest love was Broadway the beginning
of my stage career which of course took
over when television sort of shunted All
of Us movie starlets aside and there
wasn't that much work I went to Broadway
and very happy to do so I've toured with
great great shows like Sweeney Todd and
gypsy even so on but I've only actually
hit a very small limited audience that
would all change in 1984 when at nearly
60 years old Angela made her Mark in
television history Mark action National
it's a new experience for me I hope I
can pull it off Murder She Wrote is very
dear to my heart how could it not be
it's been the most extraordinary success
when I read it I thought well
if a pot was tailored for me to play on
television this is it will you both keep
this evidence at absolutely
confidential the first few weeks were
rough very rough I thought gosh can I
continue this Murder She Wrote ran for
an incredible 12 Seasons much to
Angela's surprise never in a million
years yeah anybody said that to me I
would have said you're crazy it's the
longest running Anthology Series in the
history of television now
did you kill that man
no we visited the set 14 times hi we're
from Entertainment Tonight and we want
to congratulate you on 10 years of
Murder She Wrote
celebrating with Angela as she went from
Star to boss the negative producer
remember it was a real coup to get Margo
on the show I'm one of your littlest
fans
she booked countless guest stars I had
to reach deep within myself
and for years after the finale continued
playing
Fletcher and
[Music]
so you can still do it Lansbury never
won an Emmy for her role she was
nominated 17 times she did earn five
Tonys six Golden Globes she was made a
Dame in 2014 and has received multiple
lifetime achievement awards I've won my
lifetime achieving before but that
doesn't mean I'm going to stop I
there were a few years where Angela did
slow down and once considered leaving
the business I did I just I just wanted
to have that sense of not being on Call
of uh just thinking about my home and my
family and
and it was a very good period for me
very rebuilding she tied the knot with
actor Peter Shaw in 1949 together until
his death in 2003. he's right here right
here she raised Peter's son from a
previous marriage and they had two kids
together action her son Anthony overcame
a battle with drugs to become a
successful director on Murder She Wrote
Angela made it a family affair on the
set that's my father with my twin
brothers Peter my husband with my
daughter Deidre and there's Anthony when
he was a kid my son Anthony who directs
my son David who is the exact producer
this is the family business let me tell
you it doesn't get much better than that
she thanked them while accepting her
honorary Oscar in 2014. family was also
the reason why she returned to film
it'll turn out all right in the end
you'll see I thought my grandchildren
would enjoy it isn't that stupid I
thought their kids will see it and maybe
their kids and the fact that Angela
Lansbury was Mrs teapot their
grandmother their great-grandmother that
could be kind of nice Beauty and the
Beast Angela's sang the title song in
Beauty and the Beast and also got to use
her voice in Mary Poppins returns in
2018. it would become one of her final
projects I never say retire I'm never
going to retire what do you hope your
legacy is
um that's a good question
um
never be afraid to take a chance
[Music]